على كل الاحوال سيد اندريه في حال تاكد
مقتل السيد بريجوجن واد كين من هو
المستفيد بتقديرك من ذلك
اعتقد ان هذا لا يصب في مصلحه احد لان في
الوقت الحالي اعمال قوات في روسيا او في
العملية العسكريه الخاصه او خارج روسيا قد
جملت
وقيدتر
بدا باعمال لتسجيل مؤسسته في بروسيا لذلك
من وجهه النظر الاعمال الخارجيه والاعمال
في افريقيا او في الشرق الاوسط او في
مختلف المناطق اعتقد انه لن يتغير اي امور
في اساس هذه الاعمال ان قوه فاكنار
بطبع
بريكوزن
هم مؤسسين مهمين وهناك بعض الاشخاص الذين
هم مسؤولين عن الاداره في هذه الحركه ولكن
اذا تاكدت قتله فلا يؤثر هذا شيئا
سيد مايكل مول روي ما رايك هل بالفعل في
حال تاكد مقتل هاتين الشخصيتين ان ذلك لن
يؤثر على دور فاغنر على المستوى الخارجي
والى زملاء بالنسبه الى تاكيد ما حصل حتى
الان لم يتاكد اعتقد ان الاستخبارات
الغربيه تراقب هذه المنطقه ربما اكثر من
اي مكان اخر في العالم من المرجح ان نرى
ان هناك صاروخ قد ضرب هذه الطائره ويجب ان
نرصد مساره اذا كان هو فعلا صاروخ قد ضربه
ويجب ان نسمع ذلك او عن ذلك في اي يومين
المقبلين بالنسبه الى مقتل بريجوجل وربما
اوت كين نعتقد ان احدا سيتفاجا اذا تاكد
ذلك على الارجح انه حين قام بمحاوله
الانقلاب الفاشله عرف بوتين في النهايه
انه عليه ان يتخلص منهما ولكن كان هناك
محاوله
لتبيان كيفيه اداره مجموعه فاكنير بدونهما
نرى انهما اختفي
والمجموعه ستستمر ربما من خلال المؤسسه
العسكريه لا نعرف ماذا عن العمليات اعتقد
ان هذا سبب التاخير ولهذا قد قرروا ان
يتخلصوا
الان لانه كانوا بحاجه لترتيب الاوضاع هم
بحاجه اليه ليس في اوكرانيا ولكن بصوره
اساسيه
في افريقيا وفي سوريا كما نرى حاليا وفي
افريقيا يجون الكثير من الاموال من هذه
العمليات ولهذا كان هناك تردد من الكريم
ولكن الان وصل الى مرحله جعلته ياخذ
القرار لانه اكد انه يمكنه الاستمرار
بالعمليات حتى بدون وجود المؤسس وبريجوشن
عندما تتحدث عن ترتيب الاوضاع ما هو
المقصود سيد مايكل
كان لديها قدرات عملياتها كبيره في قارات
مختلفه نسيمه في افريقيا اكرر
وكانوا يبحثون في كيفيه اداره العمليات
على مستوى لوجيسي مستوى فريق العمل
في غياب اوتكن وبريكوشن اذا هذا امر كان
يجب
اتخذ قرار بشانه كيفيه استمرار العمليات
بعد التخلص من هذين الشخصين او خروجهم من
الصوره هذه تكهنات وتحليلاتي هي ليست
واقعا ولكن قد تاتي بجواب على سؤال مفاده
لماذا استغرق بوتين هذه الفتره من الوقت
للتخلص من شخص حول انقلاب على حكومته وهذا
يبدو لي جوان منطقيا مره اخرى ليس لدينا
الجواب الشافي والحاسم ولكن الاستخبارات
الغربيه سوف تخرج بجواب هذه الطائره سقطت
بدون اجنحه انا لست طيرا عسكريا ولكن عاده
الاجنحه لا تختفي وبالتالي انا اعتقل
اعتقد انه كان هناك ضرب ات صاروخ على
جانيحين او على احد الجانحين وربما قد
اصابت المحرك في